if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
big massive dumps
dumps dumps
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
dumps dumps
[Music]
dumps dump big massive dumpsters
[Music]
toilets 10 times 15 times as opposed to
once
dumps dumps dumps
[Music]
dump big massive dumps dumps dumps dumps
dumps
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going on
jump jumps
[Music]
[Music]
bathrooms we're looking very strongly at
sinks and showers developments and
bathrooms
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
elements of
bathrooms god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements and bathrooms well it's really
a pleasure to be covering american
politics right now what a 24-hour period
starting
yesterday with the fbi
raid
of donald trump's mar-a-lago home his
personal quarters reportedly his safe no
word on whether they did the toilet as
well that's a question mark elements of
bathrooms yeah you know you've got in a
bathroom
your third element of the bathroom
you've got if i recall correctly your
sinks
your showers
and then there's that third element of
the bathroom which has been the subject
of so much controversy over the last few
days now i have to tell you as we are
monitoring the apoplexy on newsmax if
you have been paying attention to
newsmax fox news
right wing talk radio or whatever over
the last 24 hours
you would potentially believe
that what has taken place
over the last 24 hours was arguably the
greatest injustice
ever perpetrated by the american justice
system against a completely blameless
victim who was the best president in
history for the united states and who
simply won't be left alone by wrongdoers
and
globalists globalished internationalist
trotskyite socialist yeah anyway um and
of course that's not what it is and the
more we learn the more we learn about
how all of the t's were crossed and eyes
were dotted we're also monitoring fox
news which is currently
in some kind of a commercial break as
well as cnn let's take a listen on
whether joe biden is aware of what took
place earlier with your previous panel
about the former president potentially
running again and potentially running
against biden the white house saying
they are not going to comment on this
any further certainly not at length
wolfe i do want to know one thing that
we learned yesterday that may have
gotten lost in the details of this major
breaking news that came out which is
that the secret service the united
states secret service have been in
coordination and in touch with the fbi
about this search going on of course any
past president often has a somewhat more
limited than when they're in the white
house still secret service detail and of
course trump does as well they certainly
does sorry caitlyn collins at the white
house thank you very much let's bring
back our panel and daniel that's
interesting right if secret service was
in touch with the fbi about this then it
does sort of
puncture the idea that there was
absolutely no idea that this was coming
that is certainly interesting so the bad
news continues to come for donald trump
first and foremost donald trump is now
frantically searching for criminal
defense attorneys there were rumors
previously that in some very general
sense donald trump was thinking about oh
if i were to get indicted who might i
hire who might represent me the report
from rolling stone now
is that donald trump is actively and
frantically looking to hire a criminal
defense attorney now trump is also known
for not paying his lawyers so there are
real question marks as to
who is willing to work for trump and the
truth is i mean listen
it's probably the case that you could
find an okay attorney
willing not to get paid not necessarily
to work pro bono understand willing not
to get paid
um meaning they will bill but it will
never be paid
for the notoriety maybe of defending
trump i don't know i don't know but this
is a very interesting article we're
going to talk about this in detail on
tomorrow's podcast
inside trump's frantic hunt for a killer
criminal defense attorney
and then additionally bad news for trump
a court decided today
it's over the irs must hand over donald
trump's tax returns to the house of
representatives it must happen it is
time
so really just bad news after bad news
for donald trump and then and i think we
do want to be sort of careful with this
because the source is the daily mail
there are all sorts of
textural details starting to come out
about this raid
and i don't find the daily mail
particularly trustworthy but sometimes
they do stumble upon details that they
at least they are accurate they're just
very poorly sourced and then later they
come out in other
media outlets so the claims here are
about
a padlocked basement full of documents
the doj's counterintelligence chief and
boxes of classified files how
investigators met trump lawyers in june
to ask about the missing files and sort
of the oranges for lack of a better term
of how everything came to happen i'm not
going to read the entire article now
but i encourage you to at least check it
out to see what the claims are that are
being made now the major major major
news over the last half hour
is that after sending out a complete and
totally bizarre tirade last night see
this screed right here
about the raid donald trump went silent
not doing interviews not doing anything
he has now broken his silence
with another post to the much
beleaguered truth central truth
essential where donald trump said
a horrible thing that took place
yesterday at mar-a-lago
we are no better than a third world
country a banana republic it is a
continuation of russia russia russia
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two the no collusion mueller
report and more to make matters worse it
is all in my opinion a coordinated
attack with radical left democrat state
and local da's and ag's now if you
actually read through this you might
maybe you'll you would be surprised or
maybe you would not be surprised there
is absolutely nothing that is factual in
this truth
okay
first
we're no better than a third world
country or a banana republic because a
former president was raided you know
that's really
just garbage um what we saw yesterday
was
the um legal
properly documented
with due diligence t's crossed and eyes
dotted
signed off on
by the attorney general
the director of the fbi who was
appointed by trump
as well as a judge who said you have
probable cause here
now if the right wants to make the
argument that that wasn't the case well
they're gonna have to demonstrate that
and you know what presumably donald
trump has a copy of the search warrant
if donald trump wanted to show us how
baseless
and how flaccid for lack of a better
term this entire thing is
publish the search warrant and let us
see how bogus it is it's sort of like
when cassidy hutchinson was put under
oath and explained to us everything that
as far as she knows she saw in the lead
up to and on january 6th and then secret
service agents pop up pop up and they
say
she's not telling the truth and we're
willing to go and testify and then the
house committee says
let's come testify let's put you under
oath and then all of a sudden they're
missing
okay
unless
show us the search warrant and show us
how baseless it is please then he says
this is a continuation of russia russia
russia it's actually not this is
completely self-inflicted
donald trump stole classified documents
and took him to his house and did who
knows what with them
that has nothing to do with russia it
has nothing to do with impeachment hoax
number one or number two it has nothing
to do with the mueller report and lastly
there is no evidence right now that this
was coordinated coordinated with any
local state and local district attorneys
or attorneys general there's just no
evidence of that
if he has such evidence then present it
it's very much like you know mike pillow
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines over 54 countries
have now been taken by the machines yeah
if you have this evidence then release
the evidence as opposed to endlessly
saying we're going to get it to see it
at the cevosium or whatever else so
nothing in trump's truth
is backed up with any evidence if such
evidence exists i would encourage him to
release it and then we can go from there
uh they have a navy seal on newsmax
weighing in about the big raid over on
fox news
uh they are characterizing nancy pelosi
as gloating about what happened let's
take a listen and he's trying to cook up
lithium deals and electric car battery
deals and all they must be talking about
hunter right going to and then she
scrubs the internet and the transcripts
of all indications that she brought her
crooked son over there i mean he's like
hunter biden without the crack pipe you
look at hunter biden talking about above
the law i mean they have emails texts
national security flag from the treasury
department these people are so desperate
i heard a funny one earlier that look at
what's happening to trump and they
didn't even investigate hillary for
benghazi
they had
eight eleven hearings about benghazi and
remember hillary testified
under oath
for eight hours about benghazi benghazi
was a tragedy
but hillary clinton was not liable for
what happened there and she testified
under oath it is completely irrelevant
let's see what martha mccallum's
perspective is and there's um you know
likely prostitution on these t and then
it doesn't matter if he's just a screwed
up you know son of a president the
problem is that he's in deals with the
chinese and the russians as jesse just
said and they go well what
why are they talking more about hunter
biden than trump
these people are obsessed
with hunter biden
what the heck is going on
i i have no clue folks
we're on hour 24 of this and they're
still maulding i think the investigation
with hunter biden started when president
trump was in office by u.s attorney that
he appointed and i think the
investigation from what i understand
continues and i hope wherever the facts
lead them
uh that the law follows very closely uh
i don't believe anyone is above the law
i think any any person
every person is presumed innocent until
proven otherwise in our country be it
hunter biden hillary clinton or donald
trump
this conversation you know i'm always
when someone else when someone is
accused of something and people start
talking about other people trump hasn't
even been accused yet i mean there was
probable cause for a search warrant
they're acting like trump's being
charged with
all sorts of crimes for which there's no
evidence all we have right now is
probable cause for a search warrant it's
unbelievable evening last night no
former president is at his home uh had a
search warrant served in his home by the
way this guy's a democrat what was this
guy's name i forgot this guy used to be
a congressman or senator i don't
remember i forgot his name let us have
an understanding of why they did this
because it may actually get us closer to
the ending that some of them at the
table a project may actually happen you
did it again
is it my turn
i'm just an american right here release
the warrant
that's what i would do yeah accuse me of
this
really
let me tell you something
they can put anything they want the
warrant you just said the facts should
drive this oh my god not pirro she's
unhinged term you use this back should
drivers
i know you do this is harold ford jr
yeah what the facts are the facts are
that hillary clinton deleted 33 000
emails most of them that's not a fact
relevant to this case janine that's
called the destruction of evidence the
fact is she was not prosecuted because
james comey who cut her loose when he
was ahead that has nothing these people
are unhinged she seems as though she's
on on something that's absolutely true
she's also got tape all over her your
testimony before a fisa judge the facts
are they continued to lie to that fisa
judge to re-up the warrant so let's talk
about the facts the facts are that the
democrats will say or do anything to
destroy donald trump gut felt bored
gutfeld's lost interest he's a comedian
and he's just ready to get back to
telling really funny jokes people and
let me tell you something if the
president if the republicans get back in
office i don't want them to have
hearings i don't want them to clean
house i want them to start prosecuting i
want them to start to make sure that
people respond
prosecuting who based on what
investigations she's concerned about the
fact that this was not done correctly
and she's like and if we get power back
prosecute everyone
well
wouldn't an investigation maybe be the
first step janine i mean again you claim
to be all worked up about due process
here
all right stay right there blue city
mayor making a big political threat
against governor greg abbott
give me a break these these people are
truly pathetic i mean truly truly truly
pathetic
um okay welcome everybody it is another
day and even more insanity here
inflicted upon donald trump he's now
desperately searching for a criminal
defense attorney after yesterday's fbi
raid he uh the irs has been instructed
by a judge turn over trump's taxes to
the
um house of representatives
everything going completely wrong for
donald trump i'm so glad to see you i
have so many things to look at let me
first thank just a couple of people i
want to say thanks to skittlestu for
gifting two subscriptions on twitch
today i really appreciate that also
thanks to flea girl deledino's
biscolo wellbutrin warlock
all for signing up via twitch prime and
then a few people getting memberships on
my website that i don't want to ignore
teresa o'malley and melanie geiger just
signed up at joinpackman.com
and then a big thank you to jason
sickmeyer and matt wegerman
for gifting subscriptions at
joinpackman.com we have uh
the the gift list has now swollen to
over 800 people waiting for gifted
memberships
it's pretty wild what's going on
uh grandmaster benjamin feingold is here
saying what about trump hiring alex
jones attorneys well really funny story
about that
first of all
we are very very strongly working on
getting the plaintiff's attorney uh mark
uh
oh i hope is his last name plankton uh
who uh secured this 49 million dollar
verdict against alex jones he knows
everything that's on alex jones's phone
it turns out that alex jones uh took and
sent non-conception non-consensual nude
photos of his own wife to roger stone
and we're going to speak to mark
plankton very soon
uh bankston bankston mark flank and mark
bankston i apologize for that uh i i
apologize for that we're working on
getting them on look at this
alex jones sent nude photo of wife to
roger stone what could the context of
that even possibly be the picture was
among the cache of messages
inadvertently handed over by info wars
host's lawyer to opposition legal team
it's bizarre
the seemingly farcical but entirely true
development was the latest bit of
fallout alex jones accidentally gave his
legal adversaries a nude photo of his
wife that he had texted to roger stone
why would
why would alex jones text
non-concept consensual pictures of his
own wife
to roger stone the lawyer mark bankston
was the recipient of the accidental
league he appeared on the young turks
yesterday and confirmed one of the texts
contained a naked photo of jones wife
bankston expressed concern about whether
jones obtained permission from his wife
erica wolf jones now do people
is erica
erica jones is not the ex-wife of alex
jones who i interviewed years ago right
this is a different wife
does anybody even know i don't even know
what's going on with alex jones and his
relationships and quite frankly i don't
care
this is the current wife i guess
and it's not the woman i interviewed
anyway it's all very very strange very
very strange uh and we are we are
obviously
uh follow following all of it and it's
just completely bonkers completely
bonkers stuff
all right let's continue with a couple
of other things here
um oh thank you to blueberry babe for
gifting a subscription on twitch let's
look at a couple of super chats mo says
please have uh trump's attorney be
andino reynald alex jones attorney he
did such a great job i know
this is classic what about ism deflect
criticism by changing the subject by
saying what about indeed it is to those
fox news hosts all i can say is jesus
christ almighty please pray for these
lost souls
satu says wow i still do not want to get
my hopes up but might 45 actually be
held accountable might there really be
an orange jumpsuit a girl can dream
yeah i'm not getting my hopes up either
to be perfectly honest satu but we we're
we're hopeful hopeful obviously do you
expect trump's search warrant included
searches to the third element of the
mar-a-lago bathroom right you've got
your sink you've got your shower and
then of course you have your third
element of the bathroom people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times does
this set a precedent that no person is
above the law former president or not
that would be a great precedent to set
also would like to know your thoughts on
big tech unionizing i support people
unionizing i mean i don't have too much
else to say
david sir please quote it accordingly uh
correctly according to hannity's tirade
yesterday
keep your eyes crossed and your t's
dotted add that to your sound board yeah
if small fuzzy moss is in the audience
that would be a good element for the
sound board
was hunter's laptop from hell hiding in
trump safe you know chakaseki i know
you're kidding
but it's completely plausible
that that is indeed what was in donald
trump's safe although eric trump says
that the safe was empty
i mean honestly if the safe was empty
it's almost more of a concern like why
why would it be empty
because if it was on the fbi search
warrant they had reason to believe the
safe was part of a nexus to criminality
very strange every aspect of this is
weird
it would not surprise me one bit if
johnny cochran from o.j simpson trial
fame was still alive trump would at
least look into having him represent him
i don't know that he could afford johnny
it was hysterical to watch hannity argue
that different groups are police
differently as if the african-american
community hasn't been arguing that point
for decades i know and it actually goes
beyond that the um
all of a sudden now
with the trump rioters in jail
the republicans are all concerned about
unfair pre-trial detention yeah we've
been talking about that for decades
about that as a tool that makes it
really hard for people to mount good
strong defenses to the crimes they're
accused of it's just unbelievable every
aspect of it is wild truly truly wild
okay let's look at a couple other things
i have so much here to go over listen to
this
this is christina bob this is a trump
attorney now you might see her and you
might say david she looks really
familiar
where do i know her from
she's one of the hosts on right side
broadcasting
for the trump rallies she's also a trump
lawyer
she went on tv and suggested without any
evidence that the fbi
could have might have planted evidence
at mar-a-lago there is absolutely no
evidence of that whatsoever she doesn't
care
uh i i don't think that there was
actually anything there that's
worthwhile uh we'll see what they come
up with you know if they did it'll be
interesting especially since they
precluded me from actually watching what
they did but but at this point i don't
necessarily think that they would even
go to the extent of trying to plant
information i think they just make stuff
up and you know come up with whatever
they want and i that's the way that they
will have to proceed in order to
actually try to indict the president
because
they don't have anything there's just
nothing oh i guess she's saying they
don't even need to plant evidence
they would just lie about the evidence
they found so that's actually that's
argue i mean listen both are bad
but i think that that's even worse at
this point i don't necessarily think
that they would even go to the extent of
trying to plant information i think they
just make stuff up okay so another claim
again without any evidence whatsoever
which is
certainly strange
here's another wild wild claim
florida attorney general ashley moody
and the reason that florida is relevant
is this raid took place in florida
she goes why do they need to do a raid
it's not like trump's gonna flush stuff
down the toilet literally yesterday
there were pictures of stuff
of evidence and documents trump flushed
down the toilet i mean
it it's beyond parody you know look as a
federal prosecutor there are many times
where i've worked with law enforcement
to do search warrants you know
i don't believe anybody in and
mar-a-lago was gonna start you know
flushing fentanyl down the toilet like
think about the the when we use these
kinds of search warrants
trump is credibly accused of flushing
evidence down toilets
records down toilets
that's exactly that's exactly what we
would worry someone would do you know
i don't believe anybody in in mar-a-lago
was gonna start you know flushing
fentanyl down the toilet like think
about the the when we use these kinds of
um be i mean truly beyond parody these
people are truly beyond
parody um
let me see what else i had here
um jim says i'm not getting my hopes up
but i can dream hannity went full kgb
what aboutism last night he did
he did i wonder if the raid had any
parallels to the bolivians rating tony
montana i'm donald trump you mess with
me you messing with the best well trump
was in new york so i don't think so
um
donald trump under investigation by the
fbi alex jones potentially ruined it's
like a liberal christmas dream all we
need is gates arrested bo bear in
shambles and marjorie taylor green gone
that would be a miracle that would be a
miracle i'm not expecting that any time
necessarily soon
i totally believe if it all started when
eric saw hunter had a better laptop than
him yeah
very well said alireza that's completely
plausible jealousy over a laptop
could be what what started all of this
um okay let's continue because i have a
lot more stuff to go over here a couple
different things
number one this might have slipped by
some of us
because we've been so busy with other
things
mike pillow again claims he has a new
deadline for when we're gonna see big
change in this country check this out
i'm telling you after the 20th and the
21st of august the aftermath of that
you're gonna you're gonna see the
biggest change this country has ever
seen and you're gonna also see judges i
said this before everyone says well mike
what do you mean the judges you go back
a year and a half now one judge looked
at evidence except for him look at the
people in the crowd nodding they don't
know what on earth
pillow is talking about county michigan
but he didn't want to rule on it and
those judges back then they have
families they have neighbors they have
grandchildren they were afraid i'm
telling you they were afraid but in a
year and a half later after everyone's
seen the destruction of our country
what's it what is this all right so
august 20th we're finally gonna get the
stuff
this is another new one that is coming
out uh as a result of the raid on
mar-a-lago of trump there are a number
of people now
claiming
that this may be the beginning of an
attempt to assassinate donald trump this
raid now i'm going to tell you i'm going
to take a different sort of approach in
reacting to this my question is
if the plan is to assassinate trump
why does the fbi even need to raid him
first like why would a raid be necessary
for an eventual assassination it doesn't
make any sense you could just do the
assassination here's bannon
and i agree i do not think it's beyond
uh this administrative state and their
deep state apparatus to actually try to
work on the assassination of president
trump i think people i think
everything's on the table
the security ought to be at the highest
has ever been in honestly i think he
ought to and i think he should have
flown down in mar-a-lago this morning
walked out there at noon today and said
hey i'm running for president united
states suck on that
suck on that so bannon thinks it might
be an uh an assassination plot here's
bernie carrick former nypd something or
other and i believe he's a convicted
put out a tweet about this
if you remember back in 2016 when i when
right before he got elected i was in
washington d.c i was at a couple
different social events and i hear
people talking
they said the democrats want this guy so
bad
that they wouldn't put assassination
behind it
and and i'm going to tell you something
yeah they've tried impeachment
they've tried another impeachment
they've tried one investigation after
another this is about one thing
this is about stopping him from running
in 2024. okay and i'm going to tell you
something i'm not into conspiracies i'm
not into
anti-government rhetoric right he just
thinks this raid is part of an
assassination plot this is the first
time in my lifetime that i would say i
am deathly afraid for donald trump i
would not put assassination
behind these people that's the new one
this is all part of an assassination
plot now charlie kirk is taking a
different approach
he's saying we need counter raids it's
time to start raiding blm planned
parenthood and george soros
now i don't know what crimes blm planned
parenthood and george soros are
suspected of having committed or being
investigated for but that's who cork
once raided
and i'm going to say this plainly and
bluntly raids must be met with raids
they raid donald trump's home well why
don't you go raid blm for burning down a
billion dollars with a property in the
summer 2020. like who is he even talking
about they rate donald trump why don't
you go raid planned parenthood for all
of their let's just say
very revealing crimes that was revealed
five or six years ago on camera
they raid donald trump why does george
soros get away with everything he's
doing funding attorney general's offices
are any of those things that he's doing
crimes also why are we talking about
george soros
they might say well charlie we must
follow the rule of law i totally agree
it must be lawful it must be warranted
but you must have the courage to do this
i am it does does it take courage to
go after people who haven't committed
any crimes or are even suspected of them
nor are they being investigated i mean
what on earth does george soros have to
do with any of this
no longer
going to tolerate
republican attorney general sitting on
their hands while the democrats commit
these crimes forget the fbi okay the
federal bureau of investigation we gotta
hold an accountable dismantle defund the
fbi put them all in prison whoa
that's not super pro law enforcement
though is it here's charlie kirk and
newt gingrich suggesting the fbi planted
evidence in mar-a-lago uh you really are
now seeing the ugly face
of a tyranny uh and the left is so
desperate so frightened and you're
watching trump win again apparently the
last votes came in and uh his candidate
beat another of the people who had voted
to impeach him so he's now i think i
think he's now defeated seven of the ten
people with a couple devoted to
impeachment right and well in one case
kevin mccarthy talked him out of
challenging uh valedio because they we
wouldn't keep the seat and i think trump
wisely said okay i'm going to give him a
pass uh the next big test of course will
be
liz cheney who i suspect will lose by 20
or 30 points yes uh and she's part of
this i mean she is part of the effort to
turn the system isn't newt gingrich just
absolutely horrible
into a basically a tyrannical
anti-conservative
anti-republican constant violation of
the law which is what the january six
committees you have a fake committee
being covered by the fake news right
with a fake fbi uh which by the way
you'll notice they didn't allow anybody
on the trump side into mar-a-lago so we
have no idea whether or not they planted
evidence yes that's exactly right and
and newt i have a couple new uh here's
one question do you have any uh reason
to believe that evidence was planted
because that's a very serious allegation
newt that would be the normal reaction
to such a claim that would be that would
be a normal thing to say when someone
makes such a claim it's all fake the
news is fake and the fbi is fake and
everything is just absolutely and
completely fake um okay let me read a
couple other super chats messages
different things coming in thanks to
um thanks to who no thanks to no one
oh super chats it's worth noting the
current director of the fbi was
appointed by trump and johnny cochran
passed away in 2005. yeah the person
mentioning johnny cochran acknowledged
if johnny cochran was alive we know we
know johnny cochran's not alive and
indeed trump appointed the current fbi
director that's true
defund the fbi makes it harder for us to
get away with illegal things
stop looking behind the curtain yeah
they want the fbi gone guys they're sick
of the fbi
they are just absolutely sick of it
um
let's see here
oh a senator marsha blackburn went on
fox
and they're using this line if they can
do it to trump they can do it to you
i think that there are a lot of
questions that we justifiably have and
we want answers because if the fbi can
do this to president donald trump they
can do it to you what does that even
mean
what does that even mean and as justin
baragona points out
this is a very dumb talking point is the
point supposed to be that presidents and
vips are above the law
that they should get and expect special
treatment and not be subjected to what
everyone else deals with from law
enforcement it's an extraordinarily
bone-headed talking point they don't
seem to get that and they're continuing
to use it as if it's super clever i mean
i guess let them i don't know let them
use it if that's a talking point they
want to use it doesn't make a lot of
sense to me
super chat shouldn't anyone found guilty
of insurrection lose their us
citizenship yeah listen the uh
probably not i don't i don't think so
there's no legal framework for that i
would work with the legal framework we
have
i think that it's it's simpler
who would ever trust a dude named newt
fair question fair question no i'm
kidding
fox news tonight hillary's emails hunter
biden's drug use fbi scared eric trump
with ar15s so they've got nothing
nothing oh
fox news tonight is going to be off the
charts off the charts tonight
how soon until truth central starts to
lose his golf courses might be tough
without his saudi money
oh anything could happen at this point
anything could happen at this point who
even knows
uh if you're just joining us we are
covering the raid
of donald trump's home by the fbi
added on to today by a report that
donald trump is frantically searching
for criminal defense attorneys
combined with the news that a judge has
directed the irs to release trump's
taxes to the house committee
investigating
it is a lot that is going on if you are
watching on twitch
make sure that you have followed us
and if you have amazon prime remember
that you can get a free amazon twitch
prime subscription they are called bezos
bucks it's free for you to use it but it
takes a few bucks from jeff bezos and it
sends it to us make sure to take
advantage of your twitch prime
subscription
and lastly if you're watching on youtube
make sure that you are indeed subscribed
we are very rapidly approaching 1.5
million subscribers on youtube
it is free to subscribe on youtube which
is a crazy crazy thing many such
instances
as donald trump likes to say
and lastly
grab those membership folks we have a
website called joinpakman.com
we have a coupon code and the coupon
code is indict if there was ever
any day on which the coupon code would
be so obvious in its relevance it is
today i would love it for you to sign up
at joinpakman.com we do an entire extra
show every day for our members called
the bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad alex jones legitimately hates the
bonus show this clip oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad it's from a rant in which alex
jones attacked the bonus show
if there is any greater endorsement of
the bonus show than alex jones being
against it
i couldn't possibly tell you i couldn't
possibly tell you so i would love it if
you signed up at joinedpakman.com
let's listen to some of the voicemails
that are coming in
many many people
reacting
to a lot of the different things
that are being said
so
i was wondering about like the
birth
giving birth as a man as opposed to like
giving birth as a woman
um when women give birth
like their design is so
like
uh intrinsic or like
detail-oriented um when it comes to
uh
like the overall general look
of a pregnant woman in the field of
how she like goes through the birthing
process i just feel like it's so unique
it would be really difficult for a man
to replicate just based on the fact that
like maybe that would be just like oh
that little bit easier
of you know oh boy
all right i now i'm that really deflated
the stream that's not good i want to say
thanks to graveborn who just gifted 50
subscriptions on youtube that i
appreciate it's a bit of a rescue from
the insanity of what i just heard via
voicemail let's see if we see if we can
find something
a little bit more
realistic here
hey david you know i really got a feel
for the the trumps here because as uh uh
eric said uh the other day
they went down to mar-a-lago with no
notice when they raided it can you
imagine
what a terrible situation how could they
not let them know they're going to go
there and take their documents
also um
obviously it's the woke automakers that
are discontinuing the
stick shift vehicles it has nothing to
do with supply and demand all right
thank you
thank you all right a lot said there a
lot a lot a lot said there which is
pretty wild
uh
let's see here
hey david uh this is kevin from virginia
i just wanted to see do you think it's
feasible that if the temperature
continues turning up on trump
would you actually see him is it
possible you think for him to flee the
country did you see him doing that in a
way i guess that would be admitting
defeat what do people think i've gotten
a lot of emails let me know in the chat
do you think trump would ever flee the
country if things got really really bad
i don't know that i see him doing that i
really don't
but wow many people in the chat think
that he that that is something that he
might do that's interesting it doesn't
strike me as something trump would do
tru i don't think trump really even
understands other countries quite
frankly
jason says via super chat hey david i've
been drinking maggoteers all day love
these tears love watching the wright go
full speculation and deflection olympics
with so little info
these tears says jason
sean says i saw newt gingrich at an
airport 20 years ago i was in pittsburgh
and very gassy from some pierogies he
was signing books and nobody there so i
blasted him with a sausage pierogi fart
proud carpet bomb wow sean an incredibly
patriotic action that's really really
interesting i'm glad you shared that
story
uh i want to say thank you to sis admin
of a down rc moore not that dr phil
for the twitch prime subscriptions
number
61 and 62.
also want to say thanks to jason felds
who just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com
and our great friend stanley minarik
just gifted a subscription on the
website and is number 64 today let's
continue with a couple more voicemails
here
hey david i've been i've been watching
your coverage of the of the raid on
mar-a-lago yeah just having a laugh and
i gotta say
i think you may have missed the real
conspiracy here um you know when i was
watching i counted maybe two fbi agents
but i think the rest were just plumbers
i think they're just sending in a bunch
of plumbers honestly to mar-a-lago and
boy they got a real mess to clean up i
bet so they really do no that's an
absolutely fair point i think that
that's
that's completely true
um
let's see what else we have here as far
as voicemails
hey david keep up the great work
i think that the fbi reading trump's uh
mar-a-lago house is a great idea because
currently trump is the greatest threat
to this nation i wouldn't put it past
trump
to sell classified information that kim
jong-un
or putin or any other dictator like
victor orban
but anyway keep up the great work yeah i
don't think trump has any moral issue
selling classified information to
whoever if he thought it would benefit
him but you know whatever i just don't
think he's organized enough to do it in
any kind of reasonable way that's the
reality uh look there's they're talking
to kimberly guilfoyle donald trump jr's
uh fiance or you know wife whatever
let's see what she has to say i'll go
and just try to go in they were asked
about the search warrant to be able to
show it to demonstrate that they
actually had the best is yet to come
authority to get into a sealed state so
the fact that they did all of this like
this you know under the cover of a
darkness essentially um and going there
president wasn't there is just it's so
upsetting i never thought i would see
this in this country and i'll tell you
something this wouldn't be happening if
president trump was still in office and
joe biden and his administration can say
they didn't know anything about it no
one's listening to that or believing it
i can't she knows the truth it is what
they did and how they have persecuted
this man he was just at cpac this
weekend and during his speech he said
you know um i was told that i'm the most
persecuted uh person in you know in
history and he said you know i'm so busy
being persecuted that i didn't get a
chance to stop and think about that
right look at the foreshadowing there
and here we have it again you know ample
evidence of just the political tactics
these people will go to to try to tear
down this man because they are scared to
death
that he will run again so let's see if
their worst dream comes true yeah
well i want to touch on that for a
moment because i i tweeted this out this
morning and i believe that
to the extent that there was anybody who
believed that he wasn't going to run
today i think the fbi put a nail in that
coffin yesterday the fbi basically made
an announcement because right now i
think he he wow choice but to run that
he sees the opposition he needs to run
again is there any anybody within the
orbit you obviously are very close there
talking to the family has this ratcheted
up that kind of discussion
oh yeah i mean but we've kind of felt
this all along i think you know not just
as he's my you know future father-in-law
but i think as an american and somebody
that i believe in so much to fight for
this country is the president who's been
my friend as well for over 17 years and
he is a man who always answers the call
he's never abandoned the country he has
been fighting ever since he even walked
out of the white house and and left to
come you know try to live a normal life
he's been fighting all along and we
would be so lucky as a country to be
able to have him back in office
especially when you see the
juxtaposition it'd be so lucky guys of
the biden administration what he's done
to destroy this economy destroy
infrastructure destroy job all right so
there's kimberly guilfoyle weighing in
and giving her perspective a
particularly vapid perspective i might
say
laurie hart says bannon was the last
person from trumpland to be hauled
before the courts and now this bannon
the rat wouldn't put it past him to save
himself i think if there's a rat here
bannon's not spending time at mar-a-lago
i think if there's a rat here mark
meadows is a much more likely
uh
individual
than uh bannon i mean let me know in the
chat agree disagree but i don't i don't
think it's bannon i don't think so biden
forgot he called the fbi lol
right
yeah exactly
um okay thank you to
gazeen or wait hold on gasoline
and jesse prince of cats also want to
say thank you to catty catty ah
and sis admin of a down for gifting 10
twitch subscriptions that's 13
putting us at 77
and then over on the website i want to
say thanks to andrew palathorpe
james vest and mindy howar
signing up on my website getting
themselves a membership i really
appreciate that and lastly alan wade
gifting a subscription at
joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 81.
let's listen to um
do i have actually let's move away from
voicemails for now
because i wanted to review a few other
things with you guys
from my media list here
former republican representative steve
king on a potential trump indictment
they know a white man has no chance for
a fair trial in dc what the hell
steve king says
white nationalist aligned steve king
says trump will be indicted the charges
will be brought in dc
they know a white man has no chance for
a fair trial in lis in dc
let alone a republican white man
so
steve king has an opinion
he's entitled to it i mean yeah whatever
uh strange guy
this was on the show we were watching
jesse waters says that
democrats get a sexual thrill from
trying to lock up republicans
jesse they get a sick sexual
thrill from trying to block up
republicans it's a perversion
you know they like to see them dragged
out in their underwear
wow it's shocking that that show
has any audience whatsoever it's truly
truly shocking very very strange
what's this about did our friends the
good liars do anything with andrew yang
let's see andrew yang talks a lot about
robots and it's because he is a robot
he's trying to take all our human jobs
including president and if we don't
stand up for ourselves oh my god
all right that's that's kind of funny i
i don't know i don't think that's new it
doesn't seem like it's new
um
let's see what else we have
fox news talking about dark brandon a
lot
a lot of dark brandon material there
very very strange
um
man outside trump tower says the fbi
raided mar-a-lago because trump has
information on bush johnson and kennedy
oh this i have to say raid of course is
what we say bs
um they're not going to find anything
just like they haven't found anything on
the right if you told me this guy was an
actor with a youtube channel who was
just
making fun of the right
it would be indistinguishable like if we
sent a joker
to say something crazy to pretend to be
a right winger he would look like this
guy and he would say exactly these
things let's listen to it from the top
raid of course is what we say bs
um they're not gonna find anything just
like they haven't found anything in the
russian collusion they didn't find
anything on january 6. so allegedly they
think they had they found nothing on
january 6th other than 700 defendants
yeah these documents hiding somewhere
but what they really know is trump has
information he has information about the
bushes the johnsons the kennedys you
know they thought this was this boy you
know this presidential boy club well
trump's not one of them trump is one of
us so he definitely has information but
unfortunately they're not going to find
anything in mar-a-lago so what they did
is they suppressed him
is this a crisis actor trying to
suppress from announcing his candidacy
because they went after trump the
citizen yesterday and not trump the
candidate so hopefully he becomes a
candidate today or tomorrow so this this
this can just stop yep this must end
says this guy
uh let's see what else we have
in terms of what is happening today
mitch mcconnell did not comment on this
entire thing
rudy giuliani is now against
dictatorships what happens in a
communist state a nazi state
and this is what happens in the banana
republic
that becomes a dictatorship and it's
common to go after your predecessor
and their people and put them in jail
right
rudy now is against dictatorships and
authoritarianism that's that's pretty
rich
stephen chapman says if trump's toilet
gave the fbi evidence i wonder if pillow
will file a class-action lawsuit against
all toilets i wouldn't put it past him
to be perfectly frank
if trump is found guilty of a felony in
a court of law i'd be happy with a
sentence of 10 years of house arrest
after he serves his time if he's alive
he'll never be able to hold political
office as a felon
i don't think anybody's thinking 10
years down the line for trump right now
derek says does anyone on the right have
anything new to say it's been the same
bs for the last six years at least it
really has trump's been giving the same
speech for six years that's for sure
um here's trump fundraising off of the
raid
he needs 10 000 names by midnight to
stop the witch hunt 10 000 people sign
up
then they can stop the witch hunt
fascinating
absolutely fascinating um
okay we looked at that already we looked
at christina bob
um
let's see what else we have carrie lake
there's a there's a beauty kerry lake
implies trump will use the fbi to raid
political enemies like obama and hillary
if he makes it back into office obama
why would he rate obama
and tragic what has happened to our
federal government going after a former
president i suppose this sets a
precedent and and i wonder if uh people
like barack obama and hillary clinton
should be nervous
if uh you know president trump ever
makes it back into the white house i
didn't so
that sounds scary like it would just be
retaliatory not based on any evidence or
potentially investigations or crimes
that have been committed
so
if you're trying to claim that you're
the law and order candidate and you're
about due process
i don't know why you would say that
obama and hillary would be raided
just because trump's back in office
that's a very strange thing to say very
very strange thing to say
um
tim scott
let's see what else is going on here
oh this this is interesting let's look
at this ah finding probable cause so
is your issue with how you know the
criminal justice system works i mean
what is it exactly
right so this is actually very easy and
you know we're discussing this before
this has never been done in our history
that is true so first of all
that's a common talking point this has
never happened before we've never seen a
president rate it in this way right
we've never had a president like trump
so
it's all unprecedented it the fact that
it's unprecedented
tells us nothing about its uh
appropriateness to a former president a
political rival of the sitting president
remember these two gentlemen ran against
each other and donald trump has said he
might run against biden even now biden
said he might run we'll have to see
whether or not he does
uh this is a an absolute political rival
of the sitting president now we don't
know doj is just going after we don't
know
i want to be clear i don't know
hold on hold on congressman and i do i'm
trying to give you the time to convey
what you want to convey but right but
he's he she's doing a good job because
he's trying to use this vague language
to imply certain things that he's not
actually willing to say like biden
directed this to be very clear here what
you were trying to say is you believe
that the justice department under
president biden is trying to go after
his political rival donald trump because
of 2024. i mean is that what you're
trying to say here
no pablo i didn't say that thanks for
trying to put words in my mouth
no i did not try to i'm trying to
clarify that right they are deliberately
vague when they go this was done at the
hands of radical democrats in
coordination with a white house very
worried about trump 2024 he's like oh so
you're saying democrats in biden
orchestrated the raid
i never said that
i never said that right that's what
we're trying to figure out what are you
saying make sure
that we understand
they need to answer these questions
there better be something of important
national security for them to have
breached the confidence of the american
public if they would go into the home of
a of a past president possible political
candidate against this current president
this is so outrageous that this has to
rise the level of there better be this
better not be a clerical issue between
the archivist uh and the the former
president even former new york governor
cuomo has said the same thing i'm saying
on your show is that this better not be
some clerical issue or some minor issue
that the fbi has gone in and that's why
we're asking as the intelligence
committee we're in charge of classified
material we're in charge of the issue of
the national security issues and secrets
of the united states if they're going
into this man's house claiming that it's
national security that brought them in
then they deserve to tell us they
deserve oversight they deserve to answer
the american public why a political
rival of this president had fbi agents
raid his home well and just to be clear
i was not putting words in your mouth i
was clarifying because you keep bringing
that political rival right i was trying
to get out what the significance of that
would be in the relative right here
all right so you get the picture not not
super uh thrilled
with uh
with what's uh with what's being asked
um oh this looks like this is funny too
let's check this out found probable
cause but really quick and i want to go
i want to talk more about that but you
know earlier in the conversation you
were talking about you were claiming
that doj is basically going after the
president's political rival but i mean
donald trump there is example after
example i think there's like a like 25
examples of him when he was president
trying to weaponize doj to go after his
political rivals so why do you feel like
there should be more scrutiny now on doj
and not also and we see it on the screen
here as well not also share that same um
concern
back then when trump was trying to go
after him i have actually shared it
actually this actually goes back all the
way to the obama biden administration
where this claim uh you know clapper uh
brennan comey where they began the
politicalization of the fbi
and of the department of justice and
that where we saw the two standards
under so so like
understand the foundation of this
argument
um
biden
directed this and is weaponizing the fbi
well there's no evidence of that yeah
but i think he did okay but what about
the 25 times trump did that well it
started with obama biden oh huh
standards where hillary clinton was
given a pass and other people who are in
the military were not and certainly then
you had donald trump who continued to
raise that issue of what were these two
standards why was there why was he being
pursued and as you even know today the
new york times has reported that even
the uh the russia dossier that the uh
department of justice used to justify
fisa uh uh understand how off the rails
this guy is
tappable warrants uh was found to be uh
totally not even uh you know factual so
there's a number of things obviously the
president was very concerned about this
guy is particularly full of [ __ ] like
these guys are all trained in how not to
answer questions but this guy's
particularly full of it we're ongoing
during his administration and certainly
we're seeing them now also continue in
this administration but there were 25
there are examples of 25 uh times where
he wanted to use the doj to go after
political rivals some with absolutely
no evidence at all to support uh wanting
to use doj and weaponizing it for that
reason um but i i i it's these people
really are um like that was that was a
bizarre word salad
uh now fox news is running interference
by again bringing on jonathan turley
to talk about the questions over the
motive for the trump document raid they
will they will do whatever they can
i want to say thank you to luke sperry
and mickey thomas
luke and mickey just signed up at
joinpackman.com and her new members 82
and 83. also want to say thanks to pull
my finger dan
who just gifted a subscription on my
website and is number 84
and thank you also to gaz oh no i
already thanked gasoline for the twitch
prime let's look at other super chats
jay says why hasn't trump announced he's
running yet if it would solve all this
yet you know
um merrick garland said that trump
running would not
get him out of legal jeopardy at all
so i don't know that that's even the
case
um trump has the warrant if it's so
baseless and illegal then he can present
the warrant and call him out i said that
30 minutes ago stinky you're absolutely
correct
absolutely and completely correct about
that
no doubt whatsoever about what you're
saying
all right let's look at a couple of
other things
um we already did the marcia blackburn
clip we did a lot of this
so martha mccallum asked lara trump
does he does trump have the search
warrant she says that he doesn't now
understand
this is a question i guess about whether
he physically has it like obviously it
was presented
in his possession the search warrant
because i got mixed uh reports on this
um whether or not he was ever served any
document that said what they were
looking for i've just got 20 seconds
here
to my knowledge martha no i do not
believe that that he has anything like
that okay well maybe because he was in
new york but obviously there was a
warrant and
i would love to see it
released so we could take a very close
look at it and see what is actually on
that list
um
lindsey graham says he offered trump
advice about the fbi searching
mar-a-lago this seems interesting the
fbi when it comes to trump has lost
their way
this
unending desire to destroy trump and his
family
is frustrating
president trump and i got started off
kind of tough but i admired him as
president i don't agree with everything
he says or does i've talked to him twice
today
and i told him that you know there's
legal systems in this country avail
yourself of it and time will tell as to
what's going on but to those who feel
like you need to to violently react the
answer is don't what you need to do is
you need to make sure you show up and
vote stop some of this madness the fbi
when it comes to trump has lost their
way lindsay's doing a lot of kind of
like fence writing lately i don't know
how many of you have noticed that we
looked at the christina bob clip already
um
let's see what else we have here we did
the lara trump stuff
oh is david brody suggesting that they
take up arms as a matter of fact before
we get to the interview let me just show
you this headline i mean this is a
headline about the civil war according
to vino vice here we go vice with the
liberal spin right trump supporters are
calling for civil war after fbi search
of mar-a-lago and don't get me wrong
there are people that say let's take up
some arms i'm saying there are people
out there but what vice is trying to do
oh so there are people saying that
that's interesting
very very interesting stuff all right so
a lot being said
much of it speculation
and conjecture i guess i would say
primarily
okay let's see uh what is happening
over on uh cnn here
let's take a listen age 35 certain other
provisions that are in the constitution
it's not really been tested this came up
uh when when hillary clinton was being
investigated and people thought she
might be subjected to that statute 2071.
um it is theoretically possible and
there is a legal statute that addresses
the issue of continuing in office or not
being able to continue in office i think
that's a
it's tough given what the constitution
says and i think most experts agree with
that but do you think preet that this is
limited to the handling of classified
documents by the former president
because as you know presidents do have
the authority to declassify government
information yeah i mean those are two
separate things
yes presidents have the uh the ability
and authority to declassify
records and documents but there's a
process you have to follow and you have
to do it while you're in office and
there's a theory going around that in
the final minutes or days of the
administration
uh donald trump waved a magic wand uh in
the mirror and declassified the very
same documents that he secreted or had
other people secrete
to mar-a-lago it doesn't work that way
the question of whether or not there's
more going on here
is a real one because it was a very
substantial extraordinary step as you
asked me in the first round of questions
why didn't the justice department just
issue a subpoena they took an aggressive
posture i think it's appropriate to
wonder what happened here i think i
think that that is a legitimate question
like it is there more than simply
verifying whether there were a few
documents at mar-a-lago i hope so
because it is a very aggressive step to
take there's no denying that that's
absolutely true there was a reason that
it was not simply done via subpoena
um super chat's coming in is fox news
suspending their trump media blackout
since the fbi search may implicate them
maybe
maybe thanks meteor for the super chat
twitter's going nuts scott perry has
been served in fbi search warrant who
who is scott perry
uh oh representative scott perry
fbi let's see
oh look at this
oh man this is this is indeed starting
to involve more people this is a fox
article but we'll still look at it
trump ally scott perry says the fbi
seized his cell phone one day after
mar-a-lago raid oh that is fascinating
stuff let's listen
oh maybe not
fox nation presents two oh god
um
perry in an exclusive statement to fox
news told fox that while traveling with
his family he was approached by three
fbi agents who handed him a warrant and
requested he turn over his cell phone
wow this is starting to pull in more and
more people perry's pissed because they
quote made no attempt to contact my
lawyer who would have made arrangements
for them to have my phone
i'm outraged although not surprised
while this is actually legitimately
growing more and more and more
it is fascinating what is oh hold on a
second
i've gotta ban someone i'm sorry
a complete and total tool seems to have
come into the chat
there we go
yeah any any you know gay boy that's
just not going to be tolerated it's
that's crazy that's absolutely crazy all
right so we'll follow the scott perry
stuff
david off subject i would love it if you
had a segment on the impact of china's
real estate bubble on the global peace
and economy all right i don't know much
about that impact but i will research it
i will indeed research it
um
i want to say a big thank you to
christopher wood nicole o'dell brian
eakins and hayden keenan for signing up
for memberships on my website
joinpacman.com putting us at 88
very very important stuff
let's see what's happening
over on newsmax
where they are going to be interviewing
eric trump later today oh that's going
to be a pleasure i can absolutely assure
you that is going to be a complete and
total pleasure so a lot of questions
about what happens now and the answer is
we really don't know
um
there's always the desire to kind of see
through to the end of these stories
quickly but as you can see we learned
about the raid last night we learned
today about
the search for a criminal defense
attorney from donald trump
and
quite literally months may go by and
nothing else may happen we just don't
know the big speculation is
is trump now
going to declare that he is running for
president because he believes that it
will somehow shield him from legal
liability merit garland has already said
it will not
and so
there's kind of a question
as to whether it really would make sense
for him to do that
house republicans will be meeting with
trump after the raid on his home
that's a meeting i would love to be a
fly on the wall for republicans have a
moral duty to fight back
and chairman of the american
conservative unit and the author of the
desecrators match slap joins me nice to
see you matt oh no
great to be with you greta
okay matt um i take you're not at
mar-a-lago are you what's behind you
no no no uh we escaped uh to get a
little r and r but i guess it's not to
be greta
all right tell me what you think about
what's going on what's the reaction with
the with cpac i mean what are people
saying is he in some s whole country and
he doesn't want the audience to know in
a weird way
well we had a great cpac you know he
came and gave i think his best cpac
speech ever you've been there several
times greta and he uh he's really you
know getting ready covering it and
covering it yes that's right
covering it and interviewing people and
all the rest it's the center of news
uh for this part of politics and he
um gave a great speech and everybody
thought he was such a high and it went
so well and the themes coming out of it
at defending america were so clear and
boy within 24 hours
this thing happened that i just never
could imagine could happen in america
you know i remember being a
congressional staffer bill clinton had a
special counsel on his tail and they
just deposed him and when they wanted
something from him they just subpoenaed
those documents you know hillary clinton
took 200 000 dollars worth of furniture
and art from the white house is it
possible to discuss what happened
yesterday without talking about hillary
for these people like is it is it at all
possible that they can do that these
things didn't result in raids and
opening up safes and so you know there's
supposed to be a little humility when
you're dealing with the office of the
presidency and the fbi but when it comes
to donald trump anything goes and our
folks are just depressed over the fact
that we have two systems of justice
yeah you know though matt it's sort of
been look um the two systems of justice
we have are for wealthy people and then
everybody else
they want you to think there's one
system of justice for democrats and
another for republicans we do have two
justice systems but it's based on uh
wealth misdemeanor i'd never seen
anything like and this is the court
system i practiced in and you know and i
know that you know that you know it
doesn't doesn't sort of change the
narrative when you see a raid like this
as well on the president of course
president trump is not inclined to run
and hide
no look his lawyer his office was
ransacked
by the fbi now president trump's it's a
presidential office everybody has to
understand this this is an official
office it's paid for with taxpayer funds
there are there are federal staff in
that office and it's raided by the fbi
is it true that that the federal
government and taxpayers pay for trump's
mar-a-lago office
if that's true that's interesting over
the line like sandy berger who is bill
clinton's national security adviser he
stuffed documents in his pants
and he never went to jail so why is he
doing the hell just higher standard
by the way we've talked about the sandy
burger situation before shoot if there's
a risk of destruct destruction of
property someone's going to destroy the
evidence and you know i guess in the
last 24 hours i know if you saw the
at the new york times maggie hammerman
report where there were shredded
documents pictures in a toilet in the
white house and someplace else i don't
know where else i don't know if they're
using that to bootstrap it i don't know
what it is that they think they're going
to seize i don't know what it is but it
certainly is there's the picture right
there um that was all over the news i
don't know that's what they think that
they're going to get that he's going to
throw all the documents down
mar-a-lago's
sanitation system i don't know um but um
you know we still need to know what
they're looking for and have some sort
of reservation as to like
the degree to which toilets are playing
a role in trump's post-presidency drama
is really interesting clinton got rid of
thousands and thousands of documents and
she never served a day in jail she was
never sentenced so the question is
what's this really all about and i think
what it's all about is trying to make it
impossible for donald trump to ever run
for the presidency again and if that's
the end i don't i don't see i see it
i want to i want to i meant to ask
alan dershowitz about that because i
think the the the constitution's pretty
plain what the qualifications are to run
for president i don't i don't think you
can create a statute or a law or
anything else to say someone can't no
matter what
what if a politicized ag says no you're
not able to run then it's got to go to
the court we are creating all right so a
lot of very wild legal speculation
taking place here and that is uh
absolutely fascinating let's see what
the latest is here from kalyn collins
it's stalled wolf but we do know that
they had that remarkable meeting with
investigators just a few months ago
where the investigators came to
mar-a-lago they met with trump's
attorneys they were shown a room where
these documents were being held and they
later sent them a letter from the
justice department telling them
to preserve those documents until
further notice they added a padlock on
the door to make sure the documents were
secure i'm told and so that is some of
the remarkable moments that led up to
now the search warrant being conducted
and of course these major questions
about what was leading up to this as we
are now told that people in trump's
orbit really had thought this
investigation installed clearly wolff it
had not given this search warrant very
interesting and pamela the fbi met with
trump lawyers guys i mean they put a
padlock on the thing so that should
basically be open and shut
um thanks to michael dahl mike held and
jeff mckinney
for the sign ups at joinpackman.com
that is the latest on everything that we
know
and it's going to be the end of this
stream were there to be more breaking
news on this story tonight i will be
back
and otherwise i will see everybody back
here tomorrow
thank you for joining me
make sure to check those low flow
toilets sinks and showers be very very
careful about low water pressure it can
get you and we'll talk to everybody very
soon